tout en se régalant il transporte d'une
fleur à l'autre le pollen qui se colle
sur leur bec
[Musique]
les colibris se sont partagés le secteur
un chacun défend son espace aérien est
en chasse les indésirables
[Musique]
froid je suis un pur tons bleus c'est
quoi mon bleu ben le tueur que tu portes
tu t'adresses le volet c'est par voiles
sans faris et ando ben je peux je j'aime
bien ce bleu savons monsieur pat et
flippant
attente c'est pas moi c'est mon père qui
a un truc avec le plus franchement que
tu voyais neutre à passer comprendrait
en fait mon père il sort plus il fait
plus rien il a peur de tout du coup
quand je réapparais leur coûte bas je
t'avais déjà vu avec tonton sari bleus
et je me suis dit enfin je suis pas sûr
mais je me suis dit peut-être que toi
aussi tu aime le bleu le vc conlie dieu
il est si je vends de chiens
dans les eaux
la sortie de la mairie hier soir venu il
faudrait que je lui eus pas pourri
je lui dirai les membres
on dit
avec les six
pas
m
[Musique]
un gros chien comme pro blanc
les chiens avant c'était des
[Musique]
je
la musique c'est fort franchement
mais simon
dans l'ordonnancé bon là
[Musique]
mais à pas t'es sérieux là patients
c'est pour sa sécurité un en quelque
sorte que les
[Musique]
nous aimons
e
[Musique]
salut mon grand salut on va ça s'arrange
pas avec propres ouais toujours pas
abattus si c'est des choses qui arrivent
elle est bonne le pis dès maintenant dès
maintenant j'ai un bleu malgré tout
mr est là mais c'est comme ça axe qui
t'a révèle mon frère
[Musique]
m
à
a lille ça lui désolé pour hier un
système et à la hâte inquiète mais tu as
vraiment un truc avec le but du projet
[Musique]
c'est un coup de montpins châble ces
jeunes et enfin c'est marrant c'est
comme une maladie ça s'attrape comment
comme malade et dit qu'ils supportent
plus dehors et la part du rouge du jaune
c'est juste qu'il a peur de tout et on
traite à part de près là bas tu m'as
l'air d'être comme mon père dont le
voilà le départ avant le bonheur de ça
arrive à beaucoup de gens
60 des animaux à l'intelligence vive
fiable
à des patchs izik
non pas trop et toi à moi non plus je
n'y ai pas trop trop mais bon ya les
filles de la danse à son lycée à doctor
non au cours des travaux savais pas
qu'il y avait des tamouls noir je fais
pas trop de la balle
non moi je suis comorienne mais là d'un
s'amuse à la torche et tu te rappelles
du groupe en fin du clip i nuit non
enfin c'est un vieux truc mais est bien
un moment il ya une image d'une lune est
bon c'est pas un soleil ans et c'est une
belle lune avec un beau croissant même
magnifique et et un moment bas il ya une
petite touche de tristesse mais c'est
plutôt rassurant et ça me fait penser à
toi en fait c'est pas normal forme ouais
peut-être mais je suis pas triste en
vrai mais je sais c'est pour ça que
j'étais suivi ça me changeait de mon
père je veux venir me voir danser et je
pourrais nous film est vu par un expert
des clips puisque d'habitude c'est mon
frère qui le fait mais il a un peu nul
heures
charge nivard mois le chien
[Musique]
je suis tout seul
je suis commencer
20km à sortir
[Musique]
et
alors c'est facile en pas puis là et
puis après je trouve un peu d ang un peu
partout tu peu d'allongé partait est
remonté sur la cheminée
voilà à quoi t'en proville ça va le
faire et attend alors ça c'est pas ton
père c'est krishna c'est le huitième
avatar de vie chaud et je pense que ça
pourra l'aider pour ses problèmes c'est
comme un porte-bonheur
à
il a atterri
[Musique]
à
elle s'appelle sans rien c'est beau
c'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
beauté des étoiles
[Musique]
et à
[Rires]
lee
m
le protégeons
emma des mots
en mai
et
[Musique]
salut
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
et
les
ça va se tarir
[Musique]
oh
il
on
[Musique]